Playboy model Shawna Sexton is fighting
back after a fan claimed she got Ben
Affleck quote thrown into rehab
Sexton responded with quote blaming a 22
year old for someone's third time in
rehab it's just ridiculous
never drink around or with him for the
record our band has been in rehab for
nearly two weeks now
strong clap back game by shauna and
speaking of strong meds actor Jennifer
Garner is tough as nails and her new
movie peppermint we had a chat about how
she got into killer shape I saw the
movie with heart and movie critics you
know how movie critics don't react if
people were cheering a revenge-seeking
killing machine is it what most people
think when they picture Jennifer that's
exactly what the mom of three delivers
you can see that it's me fighting which
I'm proud of there was a lot of training
it was very physical I was in pretty
good shape going into it and I said to
them you know I know how to train for
this movie when you were in Vegas and
you had your back out and I thought it
was like we did a lot of things for you
but we also you know did crazy weights
and dead bands and dead trampolines but
watching Jen the action hero is nothing
new for her true-blue fans who will
always remember garner as the toughest
nail spy Sydney Bristow on the series
alias garner admits while shooting
peppermint she often found herself
channeling her TV persona leading to
problems on the set but first when we
started shooting I would I would be back
in action mode I would just kind of fall
into being Sydney Bristow Sydney
Bristow's was an optimistic young girl
whereas my character at Riley North and
this everything had been taken from her
and is coming at it from like an almost
animalistic point I mean there was a
time I walked up the stairs I looked
back over and I was like hang on let me
do that again that was a pure Sydney oh
wow that you recognize that is so good
and so tough in this movie um
what's also amazing is how quickly
Jenkins slipped back into mommy mode she
hashtag this back
to school first day of summer all smiles
last day of summer all bloodied up
[Music]